make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are continuing our coverage
on Dawn of X and we are covering fallen
angels you know after I covered issue
number one initially I was on the fence
I was like yeah I don't know how I feel
about issue number one but my rule when
it comes to comics is read the first
story arc and if after the first story
arc it doesn't really resonate with me
then I'll drop it right so I'm like okay
we got to keep on keepin on I'm glad I
did because fallen angel is awesome the
biggest problem of the first issue is it
doesn't explain anything
things are happening and that's
basically it this one is is awesome this
it's like one of the coolest one of the
one of the coolest stories from from
Donna that's right so like the best
thing coming out of Marvel right now so
what this does is this jumps back into
the past right and it basically deals
with it with a guy by the name of Yama
who's having a conversation with
quantity but the idea is that she's
having this conversation with this guy
you know this guy Yama he basically says
I've met you before the blade of of me
or and Matsu I was surprised now it's
one of the things we talked about and in
really in like Psylocke explained and
things like that is that for the
character of Kwan and she spent a lot of
her life were at least what little that
we knew in a very precarious situation
what you had is you had my own who was a
crime loose I think s how you pronounce
it who is a crime lord in in Japan and
then you had Matsuo who's the guy that
she was that quantum was at love with
who was basically an assassin for the
hand and the result of this is that
Matsui and Quanah knew that eventually
the hand in nine will basically end up
going to war with each other right
because those two guys who were
unfamiliar the hand is a very very old
and ancient organization and those
organizations that come into conflict
with the hand are dealt with harshly and
swiftly the hand doesn't screw around
and so because my own room was doing his
whole thing where he was basically
encroaching on the territory in the wall
of a hand the two tribes ultimately went
to war with each other and when they did
Matsui and Quan and were caught in the
middle and so because there were lovers
they were essentially forced to fight
each other to the death
Quan and her allegiance was was for the
most part explicitly to her warlord and
then Matsui of course was an agent of
the hand and so as a result of that
during that fight between the two of
them Kwan and basically fell off a cliff
and ultimately Chi Leo was believed to
have been dead and around that exact
same time
Betsy Braddock washed up on the shore
and that's when he basically ended up
getting the body swap between these two
characters this this takes place
seemingly long before that or at some
point shortly after that but the long
and short of this is that what she
basically tells this doctor is like
close your eyes right because what he's
trying to do is barter passage and get
away and the funny thing about this is
he says there's nobody keeping me here I
do
need to get out of this place and I need
to escape so she somebody says cover
your eyes and then she kind of goes
through this really really amazing line
where she's like there is no escape for
people like us when we're brought into
the Klan
we serve the Klan and that's the way it
is we serve until the day we die and
that's exactly what was kind of going on
here if this guy is trying to defect
he's trying to get away
and the result is that he can't ride
Quan I'm kind of sorting out her role
basically ends up killing this guy and
so you get this really really amazing
moment here and we're gonna kind of jump
forward sort of past this for a second
but we get this really amazing moment
where we're really in like right now in
Japan she ends up catching up with
essentially the wife of this guy now
basically she ends up ends up you know
taking out this driver and then you know
killing the guy and it basically catches
up to to this woman and says look like
I'm supposed to kill you right I killed
your husband because that's what I was
assigned to do but I'm going to spare
your life and in reality this is a big
no-no right this is a big no-no when the
hand tasks you with killing someone you
kill someone the masters are the ones
who decide who gets to live and who gets
to die you're basically an object to be
used to carry out a particular purpose
right under any normal circumstance this
woman and her unborn baby would be gone
they'd be snuffed out and that would be
the end of them the reason why quantum
doesn't do it is because what she says
is like I've reached into the mind of
your husband and I realized how much he
loved you and basically when her husband
was was essentially saying there's no
one keeping me here you know there's
nothing going on it wasn't for the sake
of abandoning his wife and child right
that was not only the case it was to
keep them protected because as an agent
of the hand if as far as the hand is
concerned this guy has no nothing else
keeping him here then we have no reason
to look for a wife and child but because
of the hands because of the fact that
the hand eventually learned about it you
know of course hence the reason why
quantum would send after this woman
ultimately quantum was tasked with
killing this woman and so as a result of
this what quantum basically tells us is
that eventually they catch up to her and
they kill her they they will eat torture
her for information then they kill her
right so it's one of these things were
like her fate was sealed the funny thing
about this is that quantum to kind of
make keeping tabs on it you know she
basically experienced this woman's last
moments when she was being eliminated
and she never ratted her out she never
ratted out fauna and said like that's
the woman who basically saved me that
never happened right so that's an insane
amount of Allegiance and a huge amount
of loyalty and a massive thank you you
know for these actions and so it's a
pretty big deal there but what I want to
do here is I want to kind of continue
this and I want to jump directly over to
a conversation between quanta and Laura
Kinney with x-23 and it's not one of the
coolest conversations ever right because
when it comes to Laura Kinney as long as
she's been in Marvel Comics right when
Kraig Kahler Chris Yost originally
created her annex Benevolent then she
was rolled over into
comics with joe quesada is really weird
NYX story and then from there does kind
of got rollover into her own origin and
went forward from there there was a lot
of story telling him her origin was
fleshed out you know her role how she
related to Wolverine things like that a
lot of that stuff was dealt with but one
of the big things that wasn't really
dealt with there is did she ever really
find a way to reconcile her rage why the
kind of thing she inherited both by
virtue of her training as well as just
the genealogy of wolf rain right you
guys know that Wolverine goes in like a
berserker rage and all hell breaks loose
the question was does she ever really
find a way to cope with that and the
answer of the question is no and that's
why she's talking of a saccade in here
is because her question is understanding
you the way that I do the connection
that we share here you have the same
kind of Rage that I do but you keep it
so under control the question is can you
teach me to be the same thing and the
response of Kuantan is yes I can teach
you that I can make you a master of your
rage but understand every master is a
slave and initially Laura Kitty doesn't
grasp that the reality of what quantum
is telling her is yes I can make you a
master of your rage but at the end of
the day you're still a slave to it
because what you're gonna be doing
you're gonna be going about every single
moment of every single aspect of your
life and you're gonna be working to keep
it under control right the fact that you
have this thing out there that you're
working to control means that it
dominates your life because if you let
it go out of control who knows what
might happen right so you're doing what
you're doing not because it's a thing
you want to master but because you're
scared of it because you're scared of
what would happen if you didn't master
it in the effect that it would have in
your life it's a very profound statement
to make right is a very profound case to
make you're the cool thing about this is
that you basically end up getting cable
talking directly with Kwan and her self
now again this is one of the things we
kind of talked about before that when it
came to the older version of cable he
was considered to be old hat he was
really really cool when he first popped
up the issue is that over the years and
Marvel he's basically turned into a plot
device like don't be some of it that'll
take place and the cable pops up don't
do that you'll mess up the future you
know that's basically how his character
ended up evolving over the years that's
basically what he became if there was
something that mama wanted to fix or
undo then suddenly here comes cable from
the future undoing it because it'll know
and his character really lost his
purpose and so because that is part of
this great big huge paradigm shift that
Marvel has been implementing over the
course of the last year so maybe the
last two years but what you ended up
getting was the younger version of cable
from the future
killing his future version right select
cable in 2050 years in the future versus
cable at 3,000 years of the future more
or less it was basically killing off
that old version what you're noticing
with this younger version
here is he doesn't really manipulate
time in the same fashion but he's not
using time as a scapegoat as it means to
get out of situations and things like
that he's really kind of here and then
carry out his mission accordingly right
so what knowledge of the future he has
is used in his stories but it's not
heavy handed and it's not a plot device
it's a genius way to use this character
and so as results that what he basically
ends up saying is that as far as he's
aware you know kind of again using this
side plot this this creation of
overclock that there is a place out
there in Brazil that use a slave labor I
use those young pieces I don't see how
this entire village essentially as a
means to kind of continue the creation
of this product and the idea is is using
cables information we can go out there
and we can stop that now here's the big
issue that goes on here is overclock is
basically a product being manufactured
being used or at least being sent out
there into the world by a pot we don't
really know who hey uh who a path is but
one of the points that quanta makes here
is we can't just go out there and save
this village we can't really save them
because every time we leave we risk a
krakoa refusing to let us back in I
remember ever since the events of
x-force number three when you basically
have the quote-unquote death of Xavier
the island is for the most part been on
lockdown and so leaving and coming back
and leaving and coming back at the end
of the day krikawa doesn't really know
what they're doing when they go out
there especially when they're being
extremely secretive and so as far as
krikawa knows they could have been the
ones who set up the whole death of
charles xavier now they weren't but it
could have been that they could probe
was like well maybe you did so like you
can't get back into the island anymore
until we set out until we get all this
in motion because of that is one of
these things worse like the next time we
go out we have to go out knowing who
knowing where a path is and knowing what
he's doing we can't just go out
willy-nilly and so as a result of that k
what kind of takes it as on the front
and the reason why this matters is
because in this future that cable was
raised up and he of course knows about
the notion of like the survival of the
fittest right it was a very harsh
environment very difficult for people to
grow up in but he also knows a lot of
history there and he seemed mutants
constantly being used for refer
inferiors purposes and falling in line
with the charter of kokoa in saying that
we want this island to be a safe haven
for people if only for that purpose if
no other reason than like we have to go
out there and help people where we can
because he was a legitimate good guy at
the end of the day the responsive
Kuantan is i'm not going out there and
neither are you and so the response of
cable is well then fine i'll go out
there on my own
right i'll go out there on my own and
i'll do my own thing of course he ends
up taking x-23 with him and so what you
end up getting here is this really cool
explanation that takes place between a
mr. sinister and Kuantan herself and
what is of the
on here is a quantity really reveals the
nature of like the butterflies rightful
of the guys who were familiar with with
Betsy Braddock you guys know that
whenever she used at least back in the
Chris Claremont days when she used her
psychic powers or her telepathic powers
a butterfly would basically appear on
her face and so as a result of that when
Betsy Brannigan and Kuantan went through
their whole thing Kuantan used a
butterfly as well and one of the things
that's kind of established here is that
she hated that she hated the idea that
it was really kind of a holdover from
when she was being controlled or at
least you know when she was going
through the body swap with with Betsy
Braddock and herself and so what she
still maintained that at the end of the
day she wanted to kind of create that
and make it her own identity make it
into something that was unique and
interesting for her as opposed to kind
of like this is a reminder of when I
shared bodies with with Betsy Braddock
and so that's what she's really been
trying to do in a lot of different ways
now it's not a huge plot point but it is
a way to kind of expand on the character
of Kuantan and focus on the little
elements about her because remember like
99% of the x-men readership right now
she's pretty obscure they don't really
know anything about her right I mean
some people do but like you would have
had to have been reading Marvel Comics
really since like the late 80s in the
early 90s to really understand the
nature and the notion behind like
revanche and like everything that went
into her character and so as a result of
that is one of these cool things because
Sinister's response is whoa K if that's
the case and you're trying to do your
own thing then sure like you have my
allegiance now now understand this the
allegiance and the loyalty of sinister
always comes at a price he has some kind
of plan that he wants to implement and
using pondan for his own ends will
basically help him achieve that plan so
that's really what's going on with him
the results of this is that ultimately
ends up being quantum who's basically
trying to reform herself and not really
so much as a hero and this is kind of a
cool theme because what she says is like
Betsy Braddock is a hero I'm trying to
be something else what I think she's
really trying to be is I think she's
trying to be a realist right like when
it comes to like superheroes in Marvel
yes they have a real world perception of
the world right yes you know Captain
America is not oblivious to the way the
world works right it's not like he's
like the only villains out there are
people who were just like robbing banks
you know and like whatever villains were
facing for the week like Captain America
is aware of the fact that there's like
muggings and robberies that happen every
day but the overall gist behind a lot of
these characters is they're out there in
in like the big world fighting the big
fights right so like you don't really
see stories where like Captain America
is fighting some mugger who was like
attacking some old woman you don't
really see that and it really kind of
ties into the nature of quantum because
when she looks at the character of Betsy
Braddock as this is a girl with her head
in the clouds right now this is a girl
up there out there doing whatever
superhero things she's doing but she's
not
really connected to the real world she
doesn't really know how dark this world
could be and so it's almost one of these
things where Quan is kind of trying to
become this kind of antihero slash hero
all this kind of like this Wolverine
esque Punisher type character we're not
100% sure yet but it's cool right to see
the world for what it really is as
opposed to how people would like it to
be is a very important thing because
what it does is it allows you to see the
reality of the situation as opposed to
walking around with rose-colored glasses
and so the result of this is that of
course her basically teaming up with
with cable and with x-23 going out to
help save this village as soon as I get
out there the village is basically empty
and they're met with like this giant
machine basically you know there's this
thing that initially goes to attack them
and then of course the story basically
cuts off there but for those of you guys
who watched the first video I want to
know what you guys think about this
story so far writer who read the first
issue I don't know what you all think
about like issue number two versus issue
number one cuz I definitely think I
guess a whole lot interesting but but
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to come this explain make sure you guys
have a sub button to become part of the
Rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace we've got some
new patrons in our top tiers over on
patreon.com slash comments explained I
want to give a shout out to Jason see
Austin s Jason s Austin H Phillip and
Austin B as well as Steven Z Eagle F
Joey M and Jeff are as well as Genesis
916 as always we just usually keep the
last name - an initial it helps you guys
to maintain an anonymity some of you
guys are expressed concerned about
having like your first and last name
thrown out there for the world to see I
do not blame you for you guys who have
joined up as part of our patreon tiers
that are eligible for Rob core honor
guard rings those whose rings have been
sent out you should already have them if
you're a new person who just joined up
and you've been part of this here for a
month your ring will be mailed out to
you so I want to say thank you guys for
beatin patrons
[Music]